bate isn't over here in the Berlin
district of no : many here are Turks or
have Turkish roots we wanted to find out
how they see Germany's decision to
recognize the Armenian Genocide only to
realize how controversial the topic
actually is many have strong opinions
about turkish President Erdogan attacks
against German politicians of Turkish
descent it's not my business if someone
is a Kurd or Turk but if he points the
finger at his own country then I'd say
hey stop that right now our president
says let's look at the archives Before
we jump to conclusions I don't like her
demands reaction at least not in this
manner the Turkish president called
German lawmakers terrorists for
condemning the Armenian Genocide the
official the community of Turks in
Germany believes that 80 percent of
their members reject the resolution
regarding the genocide on the Armenians
and most people here in the market seem
to feel the same way but anger and
aggression as expressed by airdrome can
hardly be found here on the market in
contrast non-turkish traders think the
Bundestag decision is the right one
you don't you young reader of Deutsch
egotist a young man when you go fish
again there Germans have learned from
the history turkey or any other country
should take a look at its fast and not
sweep it under the rug